hi I'm Kristen Bell and I'm Melissa
McCarthy and we are here to do a google
autocorrect interview bring in a card
is Melissa McCarthy vegan just ask the
steak I ate last night is Melissa
McCarthy related to Paul McCarthy very
good question I'm related to Paul
McCarthy I'm not related to Paul
McCartney this McCarthy left-handed left
hand hand of the devil
except that left hand you're referring
to raised by nuns sorry is Melissa
McCarthy Australian good night mate you
caught me down under I could be though
we don't know is Kristen Bell naturally
blonde let's find out very good well
carpet matches the drapes y'all is
Kristen Bell really singing in frozen
singing my heart out him frozen I gave
it all I had is Kristen Bell vegetarian
ding ding ding yes I am is Kristen Bell
in a sorority perfectly no but thank you
for asking my god let's do another one
what is Melissa McCarthy like in real
life a monster yeah that's very accurate
a mom and I had goo I actually googled
that before I started working with her
what is Melissa McCarthy's Twitter I
believe it has a couple of M's in it
what is Melissa McCarthy's first job I
worked in a nursing home and I loved it
I love all people
I love old people too there was really
gravitate toward I really gravitate
towards the elderly sure we do this in
the week visitors like Lyle so many
times many things because it look like
Dex I saw what is up you know these are
two cabbages
you're not even let's go to Kristen Bell
and her bosoms
what is Kristen Bell's favorite color ah
teal so many shoes yeah oh oh what I
knew it what is Kristen Bell's vocal
range
well I'll do the exact same note Oh what
is Kristen Bell on Instagram
Kristen Annabelle oh oh there's more
guys don't worry
does Melissa McCarthy have piercing Wow
above or below I have two and they're in
my hearing holes does Melissa McCarthy
have a book I own many books does
Melissa McCarthy have an Instagram it's
at Melissa McCarthy or something very
similar to that mmm yes Melissa McCarthy
have a clothing line why yes I do and
I'm wearing it I was very cute cleansing
till oil swirl coming to you and fall
does most McCarthy wear glasses yes I do
and I prefer 80's sunglasses because I
have an enormous head that's a bonus
fact huge noggin let's take it back to
Google here just Kristen Bell have oh my
god that says pets cuz I for a second
did not think it said paths just Kristen
Bell have pets yes I do
I'm down to one dog cuz man when they
get old the drop like flies um yes does
Kristen Bell have tattoos I've always
wanted a tattoo but my husband does not
like girls with tattoos I think it
intimidates him cuz he's got a lot as
you know what's weird
fun fact Dax has a huge tattoo of me on
his lower back that I'm I'm his tramps
fan yeah which is why I was so excited
to work with you because I didn't
staring at your face for so many years
does Kristen Bell have a Twitter I do
does Kristen Bell speak another language
no um I spoke Brazilian a very long time
ago
Portuguese really but I don't remember
much of anything still impressive does
Kristen Bell have allergies oh let's get
into it guys yes number one to band-aid
adhesive what a timely question are you
getting that what happened was this is a
splatter from the stove it's a little
oil and then I put band-aid over it and
as it turns out I am more
allergic to the adhesive than I was to
the grease burn by band-aid do you mean
really duct tape yes isn't it what
everybody's using critics thank you for
joining us thank you and thanks google
for finally asking what we've all been
wondering yeah
and thanks to my grandmother for sending
in most of those questions us hope to
see you soon Anna